china has launched a spacecraft carrying
three astronauts to part of its new
space station the country's first crude
mission in five years
the crew is to spend three months aboard
the country's new space station
236 miles above the earth so what will
they be doing
while they're their space scientist and
science educator dr
maggie aderin pocock joining us now
hello to your doctor
good morning good morning good morning
uh pretty high stakes this isn't it
it is um china's had their ion space for
quite a while
and they've had a number of successful
missions um most recently
uh the moon sample return mission and uh
so
having their own space station is going
to be a major milestone for them
it also coincides with the anniversary
of the formation of the communist party
in china
so it's sort of quite exciting for them
where does that leave
the international space station as we
know because that potentially
is due to be decommissioned in 2024
isn't it
it is and so the timing is quite
interesting uh china getting sort of uh
their space station up and running now
and um their space station they're
hoping will last for probably over a
decade
so um any people wanting to do sort of
uh experiments in space
they may be looking towards china to
actually get these done what's the point
of a space station
so space stations um they cover a whole
range of things
um they sit in low earth orbit so as you
said about sort of 250 miles above the
earth's surface
um they have a microgravity environment
so they're not gravity free but you know
you see the astronauts in the space
station sort of floating around
this enables people to do experiments in
that microgravity environment
which would be much harder on earth and
so this drug development
of looking at actually how humans
survive in space there's all sorts of
things that happen to the human body
when they're in that microgravity
environment
calcium comes out of the bones you get a
muscle sort of um
dying because they're not working so
hard so studying
uh people and things in space is a quite
a big industry
now i believe that nasa uh is not
according to the us us does not allow
nasa to work with china
um that causes all sorts of problems i'm
guessing because
presumably astronauts will not be able
to go to the chinese space station
that's not very helpful is it
no so we have the international space
station we have the chinese space
station
but it's quite interesting because um
china and russia are very recently
signed an agreement for a lunar base so
i think we're having sort of um
different powers of uh collaborating so
the international space station i think
is
17 different countries working together
but that is sort of
on the end of its um life now but we
also have sort of collaborations between
russia and china
now quite interestingly russia was part
of the international space station
was recently started doing withdrawals
and moving towards china
so even in space there's um lots of
political shenanigans going on
here are we ever going to go back to the
moon
i think the answer is definitely yes and
uh i think at the moment it's sooner
rather than later
for a long time there was an ongoing
battle so talking about whether we go
straight to mars or whether we go back
to the moon
and now people are talking about going
to the moon and using that as a way to
get us to mars
because the moon is so much smaller than
earth and has so much less mass
launching a spacecraft from the moon is
a lot cheaper
and so i think that's why nasa's talking
about the lunar gateway um
china's talking about sort of a lunar
base so lots of people are looking
towards the moon at the moment
and china has had a number of successful
lunar missions including the sample
return which i mentioned
so i think we'll be going back to the
nasa promise uh someone um
people to the moon by 2024 and they
promised that one would be a woman
and um one would be from an ethnic
minority so i keep on volunteering
um humans are destroying earth um we are
looking to
other areas in our universe to
potentially try and live there do you
think we could ever
live on the moon or mars
the moon is quite a challenge i think a
moon base uh is definitely viable
uh but the moon if you just look at the
temperature range of the moon it goes
from uh sort of a plus
a 150 to minus 150 so that's a huge
temperature range
depending on whether sunlight is
directly on the moon or whether it's in
the shadow
mars i think is a much better bet for
sort of a colonization
so i think a moon base might be possible
uh with a sort of a few selected people
actually working on the moon but mars i
think is the future of mankind
but as you say we've made a bit of a
mess of the earth so i think there are
many lessons that we learn here on earth
before we start sort of going out uh
beyond uh to other places so that
temperature range minus 150 to plus 150
yeah that's what i call the menopause
it's nice to see thank you very much
indeed for joining us this morning thank
you